Continuing
where we left off in the previous weeks
in the narration of Gabriel,
the prophet sallall.aii Wasam.
He was telling Giblis who we later find
out to be Jirel
about
the pillars of Eman, the pillars of
faith, the pillars of belief.
He says saiam
[Silence]
So he mentioned six things as being the
pillars of e these six things in order
for a person to be Muslim
in order for a person to have entered
into Islam and for his or her Islam to
be valid.
They have to believe in these six
things. belief in Allah.
Belief
in the books,
belief in the belief in Allah, belief
in the angels, belief in the books,
belief in the prophets,
belief in the last day, and belief in
the decree of Allah, the good and the
bad of it.
Well, we've discussed what it means to
believe in Allah. Generally speaking,
belief in Allah doesn't just mean that
you person believes that Allah exists.
Most people already believe that. That's
not particularly unique.
Most people believe in the creator and
that that creator is one. And the reason
people believe in this from when they're
children is that this is part of the
that Allah has created into the human
being.
The human being is not an animal.
Animals have instincts. They
instinctually know how to hunt. They
know how to
you know groom themselves certain
animals. They know how to build nests,
stuff that. Things that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala instills in these
animals so that they can be effective in
what they were created for. Human beings
are born as a as a blank slate.
But we have a disposition.
We have a programming
that we naturally believe that we have a
creator. Someone created us. And this
one that created us, we naturally
believe he is above us and we naturally
believe that he is one
and that we have a purpose and that
purpose is found in our creator etc. So
it's not just to believe in Allah, but
it's to believe in Allah and only
worship Allah,
to believe in the angels,
to believe in the books,
to believe in the messengers and
prophets,
and to believe in the last day. And this
is where we left off. Belief in the last
day. What does this mean? Well,
all of us are going to die. Every one of
us. There's not a single human being
that you've ever met that will have
escaped death.
It's never happened before. There's only
one person that was born a long time ago
and is still alive.
But when he returns to the earth, he
will die and live his life out just like
every other human being has lived his
life before.
And that is that person is
he was taken into the heavens by Allah.
And the prophet sallall.aii Wasam when
he went on,
he found him in the second heaven
with
and he will return to the earth around
the end days and then he will live a
normal life and he will pass away just
all of us. Every human being is
going to die.
And the last day, the hereafter,
it starts for every person on the day
that they die.
When a person dies,
the prophet sallall.aii Wasam says
that when a person is close to death,
angels that are
created by Allah and they are ch
their job is to
deal with taking out the souls of the
human beings when they die. These are
called the angels of death that a person
will look and as far as the eye can see
they will see these angels around him.
And then the angels prepare the body for
death, prepare the soul. And then when
the moment of death comes, the angel of
death will descend on this person and
they will take this soul out of the body
and they will put this soul into a
shroud.
It's either a shroud of musk and perfume
or it's a shroud of fire based on who
the person was.
And then
now this person is dead in his grave.
Every one of us will experience
a different kind of reality based on how
good or bad we were in our lives.
If we were very good in our lives,
we will
have a comfortable time in our graves.
And if we were bad in our lives, we will
have a very bad time in our graves.
But then
something happens. When the end of the
world is to happen, there's an angel
named Israel.
The angel's name is
Israel.
And Israel
was given a horn
of light.
And he is
commanded to blow into this horn when
it's time for the end of the world.
Allah will tell him to blow into the
horn. And is will blow into this horn.
And when he blows into this horn,
every living thing will perish.
Everyone will die. Everyone,
the angels will die.
Even Israel himself will die.
Even the angel of death will die. Every
living thing will die.
And the only one left will be Allah.
And then
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala after an
amount of time, we don't know how long
it is. After an amount of time, Allah
will
bring raise back is
and he will give him the horn again.
And he will tell him to blow into the
horn.
Which time is this? The second time.
And when he blows into this horn the
second time,
everyone will come back to life
and we will come back out of the ground.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will
reassemble our bodies and grow us back
and we will climb out of our graves and
then we will come in front of Allah to
be judged
and we will be judged
based on our deeds.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
will send out all of the books of deeds.
Every one of us has a book of deeds
that will end
with your death with my death.
The only thing that will continue in
this book of deeds is any good things
that continued from our deeds after our
death. But ultimately it will come to an
end.
And these book books will have a final
chapter.
These books will then be distributed to
every person. Every one of us will
receive his book.
If you are of the people of paradise,
you will get your book in your right
hand.
And if a person is a bad person of the
people of the hellfire, they will get
their book in their left hand.
And so the people of the right
and the people of the left
and then we will be called one by one to
come in front of Allah and be judged.
And there are scales
that our deeds will be weighed on.
Our good deeds will be put in one side
of the scale
and our bad deeds will be put on the
other side of the scale.
And if a person's good deeds outweigh
their bad deeds,
they will go to paradise.
And if a person's bad deeds outweigh
their good deeds, they will be punished
by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And these scales are very very very
sensitive.
Any tiny good deed a person does will be
counted.
And any tiny tiny bad deed that a person
does, it will be counted and placed on
the left side of the scale.
And then
people will go off.
Those who survive that judgment will go
to cross what is called the surat.
A sat
is a bridge
over the hellfire that a person has to
cross.
This bridge,
some people will see it wide and big.
They could couldn't possibly fall off.
And others will perceive it to be as
razor sharp and as thin as a hair.
And people will then cross this bridge.
And people will cross this bridge based
on how good of a person or bad of a
person, how much they obeyed Allah or
disobeyed Allah.
Those who obeyed Allah much, they were
very good. They did good things. They
tried their best. They sought
forgiveness from Allah. They repented to
Allah. They tried to learn. They tried
to earn Allah's favor.
They will cross as fast as a blink of an
eye. Some will cross as fast as
lightning.
And some will cross as fast as a very
fast horse. And some will cross running.
And some will cross walking. And some
people will cross so slow that they will
be crawling on their hands and knees.
And
on this bridge
there are
hooks
that will be swinging across
and they will knock certain people off
of this bridge into the hellfire. It's
when you cross this bridge, the hellfire
is beneath
and a person is crossing and these hooks
come from nowhere.
And if a person is someone who has
oppressed other people, hurt other
people, harmed other people,
someone who has spent his life doing
what they want to do instead of doing
what Allah has commanded, they will be
swept off by one of these hooks and
knocked into the hellfire.
But ultimately, once a person crosses
this
that will reach another place where
there will be
another type of judgment.
This other type of judgment isn't like
the judgment in front of Allah before
theat.
This judgment is only between the people
of paradise,
the people of paradise, the people who
managed to cross the surot.
And this judgment will be in the form of
retribution
for other things that people have done
to each other. If someone hates another
person, another Muslim, if someone is
jealous of another Muslim, envy, if
someone is
somehow harmful, has some kind of
enmity, is an enemy to another Muslim,
all of these things will be fixed to
where no one owes anyone anything
anymore. Each person will take what's
his
and then there will be a lake that the
Muslim will come across.
And this lake
when you drink out of it,
it will purify and clean your insides
from all of the darkness of this world.
All of the
arrogance, all of the ignorance, all of
the envy,
all of the jealousy, the hatred,
all of these things will be cleaned out
when a person drinks this water from
this lake.
And then people will come to the gates
of paradise.
And there are eight gates to paradise.
Eight.
Each gate
is from one side of the gate to another.
40 years travel.
If you could imagine right now if you
jumped in your car
and took off driving down the road
and drove for 40 years, not stopping.
You don't stop a single time.
No bathroom breaks, no snack breaks. You
just continue driving as fast as you can
for 40 years straight. That's how
long across the gates of paradise are.
That's how big they are.
And people will reach to these gates and
they will be closed.
And then when people are there standing
in front of the gates, the prophet
Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam will come
and he will knock on the gate of
paradise
and the gatekeeper will say who is that
knocking
and he will say Muhammad.
And he will say, the gatekeeper will
say, I was told by Allah
not to open this gate for anyone except
for you.
And he will then open the gates of
paradise.
And people will enter through the gates
of paradise.
Now once a person enters into paradise,
every single one of us will go directly
to his or her home.
Just as well as you know your home here.
You wouldn't make a mistake as to which
house is yours. You wouldn't make a
mistake as to which which road is your
road, which is your neighborhood. You
know your place. You know your home. You
know where you live. Exactly. People
will go directly to their homes
as if they've been there all along. It's
familiar.
And each person, the the smallest of
castles in paradise,
the paradise the the homes of
paradise are giant hollowedout pearls.
And these pearls are 60 mi tall.
And a person will enter into his home
and he will be able to see all of it all
at the same time.
You'll be able to see the outside
at the same time as you see the inside.
And if you're outside, you'll be able to
see inside simultaneously.
You can enjoy all of it at once.
And there a person will be greeted by
the angels
that are there to serve him or her. And
they will be there forever.
And everything
that a person could ever desire is there
in paradise.
What can a person have in paradise?
Whatever they desire, anything that they
desire, they will have in paradise.
But there are some standard things like
default things. So there are four main
rivers in paradise.
One of pure pristine water,
one of pure milk,
one of pure honey, and one of pure wine.
And a person can make these rivers go
any direction they want. They go up,
down, backwards,
whatever direction they want these
rivers to go to.
And the trees of paradise
interact with the people. If a person
looks at a fruit on the tree, the tree
will reach the fruit down and hand
itself to the person.
And as soon as a person takes one of the
fruits off of the tree, another one will
grow in its place immediately.
And if you take the a second one, it
will taste different than the first one.
You will not have the same thing twice
ever. It will always be better than the
first one. And the people of paradise
will be in paradise for eternity.
Forever.
And it will always get better and better
and better and better for eternity.
There is no end to paradise.
And in paradise,
a person will then
see Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. They'll
be able to look up and see Allah just
you would look up and look at the
moon
when it's a full moon out and there's no
clouds and there's no lights to obstruct
your view and you can see the moon just
the same way people will look and see
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
and there a person can have everything
they want as we mentioned as a matter of
fact the prophet Phet sallallah.aii
wasallam
mentions that one of the men in
paradise, one of the people of paradise
will ask Allah if he could have a piece
of land and he could farm this land and
plant it.
And it would be kind of
interesting that this person wants to
work even though they're in paradise,
but that's that's where they get their
pleasure from. And so Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala will let farmers farm and he will
let
you know people do whatever it is
that fulfills them anything that they
desire. A person will never be sick
again. People will not use the bathroom
anymore. People will not be afraid of
death anymore. People will not be ever
be sad anymore
and so forth. So in a nutshell,
this is what
the last day is. The last day meaning
the day of judgment.
And the day of judgment,
can anyone guess how long it will be?
Tell me.
[Arabic recitation]
Much longer than that.
400,000
[Arabic recitation]
Alhamdulillah. No.
You hear that? 50,000
years long is the day of judgment. But
not everybody will feel it's 50,000
years long.
wicked people, terrible people, they
will feel it's 50,000 years long.
People that are good, people that are
righteous,
people that are meant for paradise, they
will
go through the day of judgment a
breeze, a cool breeze. It will be
nothing but easy street. life on easy
street from the day that they die. Now,
every one of us, we can choose where we
want to go.
You can choose because remember your
book of deeds, my book of deeds is right
now being written. You're writing your
book right now. Every one of them, I'm
writing my book, too. That's why Allah
calls this book in the Quran your book.
You're the author of this book. If you
want it to be good, you can make it
good.
And if you want to let it be bad, well,
you can let it be bad, too.
But you are the author of this book.
So if you want to make it good, you can
make it good starting right now.
And
day when you die doesn't have to be a
bad day.
As a matter of fact, the people of
paradise, the day that they die is
always the best day of their life cuz
that's the day when all the pressure is
relieved and Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
gives you
starts you on that path of mercy and
ease.
[Arabic recitation]